[موسيقى]
لاجئ على متن مركب غادر جونثان كيكوان
فيتنام في رحله طويله ظن انها ستنتهي
بوصوله الى مخيم اللجوء الذي قضى فيه عاما
من البؤس لكن الامر لم يكن كذلك فتلك
الرحله المريعه كانت بدايه لمسيره ناجحه
انتشلته الى فضاءات فما قصته
ولد جونيثان
المعروف ايضا باسم كيهي كوان عام
1979 لاب وام صينيين في جنوب فيتنام كان
كونان واحدا من تسعه اطفال فرقتهم الحرب
الفيتناميه قبل ان يتم لم شملهم في ولايه
لوس انجلوس الامريكيه في عام
1983 وصل مجموعه مخرجين الى مدرسته في
الحي الصيني في لوس انجلوس بحثا عن صبي
اسيوي صغير للتمثيل
يدرب احد اشقائه ليمثل امامهم اختاره مدير
اختيار الممثلين ليبدا مسيرته الفنيه وهو
لا يزال في الثانيه عشره فقط
خضعك لحصص التايكوندو تحت قياده فيليبان
ليصبح مؤهلا لدوره الاول حيث لعب دورنا
شال صيني في فيلم انديانا جونز اند تمبل
اوف دوم وخلال تلك الفتره غيرت عائلته
اسمه الى كيكوان بعد تلك التجربه توالت
عروض الاعمال على كي وحصل على دور اخر في
فيلم المغامرات الكوميدي ذا جونيس في عام
1985 ثم
ظهر في الفيلم الياباني باسنجرز نوريمونو
كما لعب دور سام في المسلسل التلفزيوني
كذلك حصل على فرصه مسرحيه عندما ظهر في
دور جاسبر كوان في المسرحيه الهزليه
من العام
1989 حتى
1991 بعدها قامك ببطوله فيلم
انسينو مان عمل كي على تنميه ذاته بشكل
كبير فالتحق بكليه الفنون السينمائيه
بجامعه جنوب كاليفورنيا قبل ان يكمل
تعليمه بجامعه مانشستر في المملكه المتحده
كما طور مهاراته اللغويه حيث اجاد اللغه
الفيتناميه والكانتونيه
والانجليزيه بطلاقه كما واصل تدريبه على
التايكواندو تحت اشراف تاوليان تان في عام
ظهر كي في الفيلم الصيني سكن تايم الراوند
وبعدها غاب عن الشاشه واعتقد انه لن يقف
امام الكاميرا مره اخرى عندما عرض عليه
منسق الاعمال كوريوين في هونج كونج العمل
كمساعد مصمم رقصات قتال في فيلم اكس مان
ليتشارك الاثنان بالعمل في عدد من الافلام
والعروض التلفزيونيه قبل ان يبرم عقدا مع
المخرج المعروف وان كارواي كمساعد له اسهم
كي مرارا في صناعه ابطال القتال على
الشاشه لكن شغفه بالتمثيل لم يغب ابدا ففي
عام 2018 بعد ان شاهد كونستانس وهنري
غولدنج وميشيليو في كريزيتش فكر انه من
الممكن ان يعود معهم فاتصل بصديق يعمل
وكيلا واعرب له عن رغبته بالتمثيل بعد
اسبوعين قامك باختبار الاداء لدور في فيلم
لكن القلق ساوره بعد ان مر ثمانيه اسابيع
قبل ان يتلقى اتصالا اخر يخبره بقبوله
فشعر بسعاده بالغه وقام بتعيين مدربين
للتمثيل والصوت والحوار والحركه ليقدم
اداء رائعا كممثل مساعد في الفيلم ما اهله
للحصول على جائزه الاوسكار والبافتا وعدد
من الجوائز الفنيه الاخرى لم يقدم جونثا
خلال مسيرته اكثر من عشره افلام كما لم
يمتلك ثروه طائله كنجوم هوليود الاخرين
لكنه بكى كثيرا امام الانجاز الكبير
فعودته الى التمثيل كانت بمثابه يوم ولاده
جديده له وفيلمه الجديد كان كذلك القارب
الذي منحه فرصه للحياه مره اخرى